is Lou Dort underrated you're gonna set
him up for that iconic shot he's only
gonna do one chance you got to get it
between the skeleton and the evil tree
to our Ray Allen in the corner
[Music]
welcome to underrated the only show that
allows your favorite professional
athletes to improve their video game
ratings and today from the okay City
Thunder Lou doors the dorcher chamber
we're getting those 2K ratings way up
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
the first time you saw yourself in 2K
what was that feeling like
when I mean it was sick it was sick I
remember my when I did the face scan
that's when it really hit I'm like I'm
really about to run 2K and when I first
played I was just for my homies and I
was crazy do you use yourself yeah I do
okay sorry uh I was looking at some of
your badges I saw you're like a gold
Menace like we know that defensively
okay I looked offensively I saw your
your passing accuracy
is like 62. I'm not way better than that
if somebody was here that could change
your ratings do you know what you'd say
to them bring it out
Ronnie get in here
[Music]
let's go
what's up bro good oh yeah how strong of
a player is he in the game he's one of
the most popular my team cards that we
have and I think it's one of those like
360 players offense defense but that
passing attribute I know I know he's
upset about it so we're gonna see what
we can do today we have a few historic
amazing passes that we're going to have
you recreate because we need a wow
moment for Ronnie 2K are you ready yeah
let's do it
[Music]
foreign
so the first one we want to recreate is
Kobe's alley-oop to Shaq
2000 Western Conference Finals when he
just left it for him we have an
abominable snowman that I feel like is
15 feet high can you even see the basket
right now barely Barry that's Brian
Grant okay so you're gonna have to
dribble up float it and there's a a
basket right next to the hoop that you
need to drop the ball in okay
so the goal Lou is you put it in that
basket this is to show your accuracy as
a passenger this thing's gonna be easy
it's doable I can do it all right so
whenever you're ready man
[Music]
here he goes
I feel like Shaq could have caught yeah
[Music]
but now the confidence is building
you see
[Music]
all right second one Lou we are
recreating the Chris Bosh rebound and
then like one-handed dish to Ray Allen
iconic moment it's not only about
getting it in this proximity you got to
set him up for that iconic shot he's
only gonna do one chance you should know
this better than anyone catch up I'll be
ready to shoot so you want it in I want
it I want it in the pocket in the pocket
okay how are you feeling about this I
can do it there's a lot of tall stop in
front of me you got to get it between
the skeleton and the evil tree to our
Ray Allen in the corner would you say
this is going to be a bit spooky
all right whenever you're ready
[Music]
that's what I like to see it doesn't get
more pocket than that
he uh he's not doing something I just
think Ray Allen is a little bit uh
two for two
so Lou door entered today a 62 passing
accuracy first drill recreating Kobe to
Shaq laid it in the cage second drill
recreating Chris Bosh to Ray Allen hit
him right where you want it in the chest
Falls in your court is Lou Dort
underrated is his passing accuracy going
up his passing writing seems to be
unrated underrated
Vindicated yeah and now celebrated Blue
Door love congratulations
that's what we do that's what we do Lou
door going up
foreign
[Music]